[Music]
inside of you is brought to you by sonos
i don't know how many times i have to
talk about this because i i love talking
about this but uh if you don't know
i have if you're a listener you probably
do know but you know how much i love
sonos uh they
weren't my sponsor for the 18 years that
i had sonos all over my house and i kept
asking cumulus uh agnes and uh theresa
over there to to see if sonos would be a
sponsor and finally we got them to be a
sponsor i think this is
they have some of the greatest products
there is around i have
uh a sonos you don't have you know the
old days where you have like a
a giant what do you call it um boom box
receivers and all these things in the
house you just don't need that anymore i
have a computer and i have sonos i have
a small device in each room that plays
music wonderfully loudly clearly
beautifully they say beautifully maybe i
did but uh sonos is fantastic um share
the joy of listening on sonos this
season make the sound system on your
wish list a reality with speakers and
sound bars that are easy to set up so
easy guys i i do this i
have no patience and i can do this
they're easy to use
and all work together so you can listen
in any or every room and bring the
family together with incredible sound
for everything from classic carols to
festive films sonos works with all your
streaming services and control is simple
with the sonos app your voice using
amazon alexa or google assistant and
apple airplay 2 spoil the listeners in
your life with a gift that keeps on
giving treat gamers and movie lovers to
an immersive home theater experience
with beam
keep your fitness loving friends
motivated with great sound for their
workout playlist with move
and help relatives relax with hands-free
control of their music and more on sonos
one you've got to try sonos it will
change your freaking
lives i like i said i've got them all
over my house and
what's nice is
i'll play uh you know some meditation
music in the basement i'll just get my
meditation on my yoga on if i have to
um
my bedroom i'll have something chill
that if i want to go to bed
in the living room i'll have some
you know some 80s playing kicking you
know outside maybe i'll have a some jazz
i don't know jazz some jazz i mean you
could do it all with sonos you could
play songs in each room in your house
it's wonderful and all you have to do
folks do me a favor go to sonos.com it's
sonos sonos.com to learn more and wrap
up your holiday shopping you won't be
sorry you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum hi guys how are
you are you enjoying your week i know
you're driving i hope hopefully you're
smiling come on smile let me just feel
it are you smiling now
let's do it let's just try to have a
good day let's have a freaking good day
thanks for uh making me part of your day
ryan tayez is here with me i am here
with you today and um
i'm not i am spirit
you're here in person i'm here and
that's good yeah that's nice
um i like having you uh you have a good
week yeah yeah i mean yeah yeah you have
a good thanksgiving it's great it was
great you loved the family loved it
i love your family i don't know them but
i love them
yes i love them i love them too did you
have a nice thanksgiving i did it was
nice to have friends over and uh
you know just we all sit around we all
say what we're thankful for and i think
it's important you know i used to think
hokey can't be cheesy
you know and then when you sit around
you say hey i'm thankful for you i'm
thankful for my patrons i'm thankful for
to have a job i'm thankful for having
ryan here i'm thankful for
it makes it just something to the brain
it's science people have talked about
this doctors and everything but there's
something about being grateful and
saying your gratitudes that help we've
talked about this in the podcast before
but i'm grateful for all of you guys um
so hopefully had a great thanksgiving
we're gearing up for christmas the
hanukkah season
and uh i like it i like the weather i
like a little chilly outside don't you
yeah it's nice it is so yeah i like to
go shopping yeah i like uh i like like
sporting a little hoodie yeah
just like a little just like a little
cozy that's right that's what i like to
do thank you for listening to this
podcast thank you for supporting it ryan
tell them how they could follow us the
hand what are the handles on instagram
and facebook they are at insideviewpot
on twitter and that inside of your
podcast on instagram and facebook
there you go so you could follow us you
could listen to us you could listen you
could watch us on youtube please
subscribe uh if you're here for nick
frost if you're a fan of nick frost i
hope you'll stay around and listen to
other episodes i think you'll enjoy it i
think you'll get something from them i
really do believe that so hopefully
you'll uh you'll join me and thanks to
all the patrons who give back to the
podcast you can go to patreon.com inside
of you and you could give to the podcast
more and keep this thing running thanks
cumulus happy holidays thanks ryan
thanks bryce thanks jason my editor um
today we have a great guest nick frost i
i am a big fan of nick frost um and you
know his his partner in crime simon
pegley did a lot of movies together sean
of the dead and uh the list goes on but
um
you know he's he really has a great
story he has a book that's out and um
he speaks from the heart it's not like
some actor just telling you like here's
my story this is a guy who you know
had some tough times and he opens up
about it he opens up about his sister
dying
and uh nick i appreciate you man i
appreciate you opening up and being so
damn humble and sweet and i think a lot
of people are gonna get a lot from this
podcast today so without further ado
let's get inside of the great nick frost
it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience what is it uh that's uh raiders
of the lost ark that is indeed that's
indie gold lovely yeah isn't that nice
do you have any toys at your house nick
do you have any toys
no you know what i don't have anything
at all like nothing from any job i've
ever done
like when you go to simon's house it's
like a museum of peg
but like i literally you've got nothing
of any oh i and i found like an old
poster that tintin posted that steven
spielberg signed the other day i was
like oh maybe i'll keep it oh you had
steven spielberg sign your tin tin
poster
yes it was one of the big ones you get
in the premieres when you walk in
someone got got that and someone signed
it all and it was in an office that i've
forgotten about and they said oh do you
still want to keep this i was like yeah
so that's the only thing you have all
the movies you've done all the big
actors you've worked with you don't keep
anything you don't really care about
that stuff
no i never
no no i don't i don't not care but
uh you know i have to i have to weigh up
is it
is it just gonna be stuck in a [ __ ]
cupboard for a year
and if it is then i probably don't need
it
i got i'll tell you what i've got when i
was like 16
and like i had no money
and i used to go around what do they
call them in in the states like
we call them charity shops but you call
them
uh
thrift store
thrift stores so i used to go
walking around thrift stores with the
aim of finding like
a first edition novel
and then being able to sell it and like
eating
really one one day i found the
first edition novelization
of close encounters of the third kind
so spielberg wrote it as a novel well i
didn't know that
oh my god it's amazing the dust jacket's
pristine
and then when i got to do tintin with
him i brought that with me to los
angeles and i got him to sign it and he
was like oh my god this is amazing i've
never seen
you think you saw two of them
wow did you get star struck did you have
you read that book i haven't read it but
i've seen close encounters with the
third kind
okay so you know the big organ they play
at the end
[Music]
so in the book it explains that
the only place in the world that the
secret service
could get a synthesizer
uh advanced enough
was off of stevie wonder
there's like a whole [ __ ] scene where
the fbi turned up at stevie wonder's
house
like in the book no come on
honest to god
they go to stevie wonder's house
yeah and they like commission like they
they kind of they say listen we can't
tell you what it's for but we need one
of your synthesizers does it take you
out of the book does it kind of like is
it kind of goofy or it works
it made it better i wish stevie wonder
had been in the film
now that's one of your favorite films
right close encounters
yeah i [ __ ] i love it i love it i
mean
i could
i watch bits of it now i find the end
there's like a bit at the end before the
very end that kind of lags when they're
running up devil's tower and stuff and
you know they're spraying that
sleeping gas on the birds or whatever it
is that that kind of lags a bit for me
now but
i remember like
my auntie melanie who's a vampire uh
wait wait she's a vampire what do you
mean she's a vampire well she's never
aged it's really weird and she never
comes out in the day right uh she just
gets up at like six in the evening
and then sits up all night drinking tea
and smoking and then he's in bed
all day she's probably in her 70s but
she looks she looks like kate bush
but she lives in a place in wales that
used to have
an american air base
and so she used to date all the american
service guys
and uh she was dating this guy
and he got us onto the base
what are those things called in base
they're called px's or like
they're like shops that you can buy
american food right i know like wales
so
that was the first time i ever ate a
pizza
like he got us onto the base and we had
pizza how old were you
like
10 11 right right
and then one afternoon we were at my
auntie's house
and he came around with like a massive
videotape
and it was close encounters
and so he like put it on and we all sat
and watched close encounters on vhs so
it's kind of a special memory it's a
special movie because that's like one of
the first
movies you probably saw we had pizza i
mean you know
you know what films like in television
it has that kind of amazing i i find it
with old photographs too you know that's
how we can time travel as humans you
know because it we can't physically
travel but you can
i can feel how i [ __ ] felt when i was
10 you know it's amazing yeah it's me
and simon we when we did paul
we hired a massive rv and we drove
the whole route that the guys drive in
the film right
and it took us like
eight nine days you know we drove from
la to vegas and then to area 51 and
up through utah and and
it was an amazing journey but
the whole point was we got to devil's
tower
and then we walked around the tower
with a soundtrack on our ipods
and uh
[Music]
and so it took us like seven days to get
there and like an hour before we arrived
in devil's tower
he and i ended up having like a big
argument and then we ended up walking
around devil's tower on our own
oh my [ __ ] way for that i wonder what
the argument was about that's what
interests me
do you remember oh my god it was just
[ __ ] i mean we haven't
what are we are you i remember us
we've had probably had two
two really big arguments
i remember we we shared a bed for like
ages for like a year you shared a flat
together you slept in the same bed you
and simon's yes yeah we did
and uh one night we were
we were chatting you know before we fell
asleep
and i was kind of craw i crawled down
the bed on all fours
and he thought it would be funny to kick
me off the bed
and it just went really badly wrong it
just
and we just we had a massive argument
and then
we kind of went we went to bed back to
back and just fell asleep like that oh
my god just powered you've been looking
at one another my who usually starts it
who usually provokes the other the most
well we're different see he
i don't know i'm different now being a
50 year old man i've had to let a lot of
those
resentments go you know right but when
we were but much younger it was
you know i guess uh
i don't know simon's very clever he's
very good at arguing
he's not always right but he's good at
arguing do you know what i mean right
so it can be quite
quite frustrating arguing with simon
because it's like
i'm not gonna [ __ ] win this so i
might as well shut the [ __ ] up you know
uh
the late carrie fisher i was friends
with her name drop but she used to she
used to be married to paul simon and she
said they would get in these vicious
arguments together
and he would say some of the most
brilliant [ __ ] up distorted clever
things during their argument that she
would say
i'll be right back and go in the other
room and write them down
yeah because she couldn't believe what
he was saying so she would write those
clever uh yeah i thought that was pretty
amazing so it's one of those things
where he's just really clever and you're
like [ __ ] i can't win with this spot
yeah exactly
you know you and i met in a at a
convention in australia
right do you do you go to a lot of the
conventions and how do you like them
um well i haven't been i mean because of
kovid that's kind of shut that path down
for for the time being
um
i really
i've got to say i mean in theory i
should [ __ ] hate going to conventions
and and meeting people and
smiling and
well why is that why is that are you an
introvert you feel i am yeah i'm uh i've
got adhd so i find it difficult to get
out to leave the [ __ ] house sometimes
you know
um
kind of lots of weird anxieties and
you know but
but
i i really like it i really like doing
it you know it doesn't
it never really feels like what work i
mean i know you get tired and you get
paid for it and stuff like that and you
can never
i mean as you i mean you don't know
you're really professional at these
things you're always
lovely to everyone you know and that's i
think that's the key to make everyone
feel like
they are special for that minute two
minutes that right also i'm really aware
that they potentially
pay a load of money just to come and see
you and to have a photograph and
you know
i i i'm always aware that that's a
that's a factor you know right because
some people turn up they want [ __ ]
ten pictures and loads of things signed
you know cricket bat and it's like dude
it's like 400 bucks for you
do you i do do that thing where you kind
of give go on at this one you know i'm
terrible like that oh yeah if someone
comes in and goes oh i don't have any
money i'm like just pick something just
[ __ ] grab something now everybody
that's listening is going to go i don't
have any money right and
yeah
but there's a lot i mean
you know it's kind of amazing though in
terms of my fan base wherever i've gone
in the world to do a comic on
the kind of people are always the same
you know what i mean they're all exactly
the same person and i kind of like that
continuity there's something
like watching close encounters i know
how it works right
right it's sort of like the same fans
like you know you have that fan base
people shawn of the dead hot fuzz the
world's in paul that kind of that kind
of feel to it
right yeah absolutely yeah the the genre
geek
yeah
you know i mean i think they get a sense
from the stuff we do and
is is
i mean it's correct in a certain
aspect but we i mean that was us i mean
that we are fat we are fans of the genre
and you know i love close encounters and
science fiction and star wars and star
dragon you know it's
i like it all so it's i get it i
understand you know
inside of you is brought to you by sonos
i don't know how many times i have to
talk about this because i i love talking
about this but uh if you don't know
i have if you're a listener you probably
do know but you know how much i love
sonos uh they
weren't my sponsor for the 18 years that
i had sonos all over my house
and i kept asking cumulus uh agnes and
uh theresa over there to to see if sonos
would be a sponsor and finally we got
them to be a sponsor i think this is
they have some of the greatest products
there is around i have
uh a sonos you don't have you know the
old days where you have like a
a giant what do you call it um boombox
receivers and all these things in the
house you just don't need that anymore i
have a computer and i have sonos i have
a small device in each room that plays
music wonderfully loudly clearly
beautifully they say beautifully maybe i
did
but uh sonos is fantastic um share the
joy of listening on sonos this season
make the sound system on your wish list
a reality with speakers and sound bars
that are easy to set up so easy guys i i
do this i
have no patience and i can do this
they're easy to use
and all work together so you can listen
in any or every room and bring the
family together with incredible sound
for everything from classic carols to
festive films sonos works with all your
streaming services and control is simple
with the sonos app your voice using
amazon alexa or google assistant and
apple airplay 2. spoil the listeners in
your life with a gift that keeps on
giving treat gamers and movie lovers to
an immersive home theater experience
with beam keep your fitness loving
friends motivated with great sound for
their workout playlist with move and
help relatives relax with hands-free
control of their music and more on sonos
one you've got to try sonos it will
change your freaking
lives i like i said i've got them all
over my house and
what's nice is
i'll play uh you know some meditation
music in the basement i'll just get my
meditation on my yoga on if i have to
um
my bedroom i'll have something chill
that if i want to go to bed
in the living room i'll have some you
know some 80s playing kicking you know
outside maybe i'll have uh some jazz i
don't know jazz some jazz i mean you
could do it all with sonos you could
play songs in each room in your house
it's wonderful and all you have to do
folks do me a favor go to sonos.com it's
sonos sonos.com to learn more and wrap
up your holiday shopping you won't be
sorry inside of you is brought to you by
my good friends at better help better
help online therapy
boy i can't tell you how much this works
i get emails all the time thank you for
talking about better help thank you for
getting me into to therapy ryan does
better help i do
i just you know uh i just had a friend
this morning i was facetiming with him
and his wife said you know my kids uh
dealing with depression and uh do you
know any good therapist i go better help
online therapy because they're in the
middle of sort of nowhere and you don't
need to go anywhere you can facetime or
text or you know it's it's better help
is just uh it's amazing it's helped you
out yeah it's a it's convenient yeah it
has been good i have gotten a lot out of
it well i like that look whether you're
struggling with grief relationships or
stress or having trouble sleeping or
meeting goals online therapy might be
for you better help is secure online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with a licensed
professional
therapists better help will assess your
needs and match you with your own
accredited therapist you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours and
you don't have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room
therapists have a broad range of
expertise which may not be available in
your area
the service is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime folks
send a message to your therapist you'll
get timely and thoughtful responses plus
you can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change therapists if
you need and that may happen you know
you meet someone the first time you may
not vibe with them you change your
therapist better help it's that easy
and i i completely recommend this uh so
many people have told me it works uh
it's more affordable than traditional
offline therapy by a landslide if you
ask me and financial aid is available
visit betterhelp.com
inside and join over the 2 million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional in fact so many
people have been using better help ryan
that they are recruiting additional
therapists in all 50 states
inside of you is sponsored by betterhelp
and our listeners get 10 off their first
month of online therapy at
betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp.com
inside give it a shot
better help inside you is brought to you
by home medics guys you know
i've got a rough back a rough neck i've
had lots of surgeries i don't
necessarily sleep that well
but uh
homedics really makes great products
they sent me this back massager
and you could prop it up against a wall
you could lie flat on it and
it's so deep
and just penetrates the hell out of you
it it really just
it just helps me after a long day i'm
all knotted up i'm tight
and uh oh
baby home medics really did it i swear
lally came over the other day if you
don't know lally's one of my best
friends from childhood i go dude
lay on that sucker
and lolly's like no i'll do it later go
no bro
do it now
now
and he lied on he's like
whoa
that was his reaction just uh fantastic
um
homedics really knows how to make great
products and homedics has a slew of
products they've got a whole line of
massage products from a massage gun with
built-in hot and cold technology to a
massage cushion that lets you lie down
or sit up like i was talking about
depending on your therapeutic needs to a
three in one foot massager with
vibration so powerful it loosens the
muscles in your legs and lower back
moral of the story homedics has
massagers that address your pain points
from head to toe um i love this product
i use it i could i could honestly say i
used it and love it and it works and so
now i'm telling you and you know what
they also have an a plus better business
bureau rating so you know they're a
brand that you can rely on a plus a plus
wow so you can join the millions of
customers who trust the home edicts
family to take care of theirs whether
you're dealing with chronic pain or just
looking to help your muscles recover
from a workout we've got good news
right now if you go to homemedics.com
inside and use the promo code inside
you'll receive a free portable phone
sanitizer when you buy a hundred dollars
or more in massage products that's a 60
value that's homedics h-o-m-e-d-i-c-s
dot com
slash inside and use the promo code
inside for your free portable phone
sanitizer with a hundred dollar massager
purchase
now you were saying
you know you suffer from 80d i you know
i i i deal with the same stuff i've
dealt with my whole life i get
overwhelmed very easily what it what is
it that do you have you dealt with
depression your whole life and anxiety
and things like that and what do you do
for it
yeah look i mean
i think it's only
really in the last kind of three look i
mean
i think i
sorry i'm just trying to think of a
a nice you know look
i think it's from the age of like
16 i just suffered
a lot of trauma until i was
40. you know literally
uh you know violence and death and
people dying and [ __ ] cancer and
alcoholism and addiction and just just
and i got very good at
just
laughing and smiling and let's do
another joke yeah um you know let's
let's just let's keep going let's just
it'll be fine you know and you kind of
get
you kind of get good at pushing it down
and ignoring it you know
um not realizing that it's it doesn't
for me it didn't go away you know it
just
built up and built up and built up and
then
you know
it got to a point a few years ago it's
like i i don't think i can
i don't think i can live like this
anymore as a human i
it just felt like i'd been through so
much that
um
i did there was no you know i just felt
there wasn't
a human shouldn't
suffer that much
yeah so i decided to do something about
it you know and that that was i never
realized i had adhd until three years
ago you know
and um you know getting that diagnosed i
was like okay that that makes a lot of
sense in terms of
the way i react to noises and pressure
and
you know i'm not good at
i'm not good with people or
you know i work well under pressure i
need lists i need uh
you know
i can't deviate from a plan i you know i
try to control everything and
you know even now like today's i'll get
up at [ __ ] 3am and make a cake and
then i'll drink 10 coffees and go and
paint for an hour and then the kids get
you know it's like
i do feel super human with it but
there's there comes a very
uh very dark side to that too you know
yeah what do you what do you do with
that because i i deal with that too
where
i'm just overwhelmed i can't you know
when you say you have a plan you have to
stick to that plan when somebody goes
well what if we do this i'm like that
gives me anxiety wait a minute you're
talking about changing the plan up so
how do you deal with that it's like you
know i t you know i take something but
uh is it something that you know you
have to work on or be conscious of and
then uh yeah
yeah i mean look this is all part of my
issue in terms of
you know there's an element there of of
control that
i need
to feel safe you know
um
but part of part of of me
not being so sad and and
self-destructive and and
is about letting letting go and trusting
that
all right you know let's see
i haven't got the answers so let's just
see how it plays out because it it
affects everyone around me you know it's
also i'm also aware again to that weird
loop i'm aware that
it's really
unattractive and ugly
to be [ __ ] sad all the time and to be
depressed and to want to control things
and want to make people do what i want
to do and
oh don't do it like this you'll be
better you'll be happier if you do this
if you if you listen to what i say
you'll be happy and then i'll be happy
you know it's it's tiring for people to
disaster my partner my lady is
it's it cost me uh a marriage you know
and it's i
you i i become very aware that it's
it's really [ __ ] ugly and it's really
hard to live with and then that of
course triggers off
why are you with me why are you you know
and and that's when you know
as as a
you know someone who has depression and
and other bits and pieces going on
upstairs it's it's
you then start to trigger yourself and
that's when
you know you can really [ __ ] yourself up
yeah and you don't drink anymore right
i don't no i don't do anything i mean i
haven't drunk for eight for
ages really um
i just you know what i mean
literally every big fight
or argument i've ever had with a partner
girlfriend has been because we've been
pissed you know
and it just got to a point it's like i
just don't i don't need it you know my
mom and sister both died of alcoholism
so i'm aware that it's there it's in my
family you know so it was like
[ __ ] that i don't need it you know yeah
you know it's that thing it's
you know and i can recognize that thing
in myself where
because of i i i
i don't mean to sound like a dick but
because obviously i've achieved a
certain level of success on the tv
you're kind of well known i'm kind of
well known over here so i tend to to not
drink in the evenings
so i'd go and be in the pub at one in
the afternoon
you know and then i'd sit there until
six or seven and then when people
started to come in then i'd leave
but then you'd be leaving with
eight cans of budweiser and a bottle of
wine and
you know you'd finish that and you think
oh what have i got in that cupboard you
know what i mean it just was never
enough right and i think at that point
you start to think
okay let's see i see what's happening
see what's happening here yeah i mean
look most people write a book a book a
memoir when they're like betty davis
when they're in their 70s or their 80s
right but i was like this guy must have
lived a [ __ ]
life if he's writing a book you have the
memoir that came out a couple years ago
truths half truths and little white lies
and you you get into it all
but what what prompted that did you feel
like [ __ ] i've lived i've had a lot to
tell maybe i could help someone what was
the reason behind it
um yeah i mean i just got approached by
uh by the publishers say did you wanted
did you want to do one and i wasn't um
i never really thought about it but i
you know
i think
i i i lost my parents like
i lost my mum when i was like 35 and i
lost my dad like 12 years ago
like seven years after my mum
and i was really aware that there were
portions of my
life
that i had lost forever now because i
could never ask them
they were gone and i think there was a
regret that
there were things that i sh
that i didn't ask as a kid because you
don't you just don't ask your parents
yeah what is that you never i don't feel
comfortable yeah well you know
i just never did it and then there were
things and now i mean
i'm not i don't really i'm not bothered
anymore by it but i was like okay so
maybe if i could write down stuff and
stuff that my kids could read when
they're like older and they're like oh
can i get a sense of who dad was not
just
an idiot who did films that we were too
young to watch you know right right but
it was also quite what i kind of liked
about
about hannah who published the book
is she didn't want it to be celebrity i
just didn't want it to be
a kind of you know i kind of hate that
thing well i'm in a very
i'm always aware that the job we do
puts us in a very kind of
a bracket where
i hate seeing celebrities moaning about
you know crocodile shoes that are too
tight or they are [ __ ] jet lagged
they just got off a private plane and
you know i just think boo [ __ ] who
yeah so you want something to be that
you know
and so i just wrote up until
i was 30 so i didn't even do any any of
the getting on tv or doing sean on the
dead you know and i just wanted to
you know i thought if
and
i i do get a lot of dms from people to
say hey i read your book and
it helped you know because it talks
about depression it talks about grief
and loss and
you know i just think
western culture is so
[ __ ] at dealing with death still like
it's a big [ __ ] surprise and
you know
i mean my kids i've got a newborn and a
three year old and a 10 year old and
i will be
i've heard of something like ages years
ago it's kind of stuck with me like
some guy some
like warchief from
the
you know some amazing
tribe said that like the point of being
a father is to prepare your
children for the fact that one day
you're gonna die
and i was like oh [ __ ] i kind of get
that you know right and so there's i
mean it's difficult to do
now
in our kind of society but
you know i talk about death a lot with
my son not in a weird kind of
creepy frightening way but just like
yeah this is how it is this is
this is part of it you know
right so they're very aware of the kids
i mean you you talk to them are you do
you feel like you're pretty open like
was your father when you were
growing up was your father open because
my father wasn't open at all i didn't
know anything about him i still don't
know anything about him and so sometimes
you know that's just that old school
traditional sort of like you don't need
to know about me you don't need to be my
friend you know i'm going to put a roof
over your head and that's [ __ ] it i
mean you know how was your father
my look well my old man was
you know
he he was he was a he was an amazing man
you know he
he i think he had a lot of trouble with
he was a very funny man he was a great
cook
um him and my mum were quite romantic
and affectionate to one another wow um
i'd watch them dance sometimes in the
kitchen which was amazing and
um
but but you know he had a
my my mum had a terrible drink problem
so i could see him start to
have to cope with that too
and i thought that that that that
that was quite something you know
and then my dad he he was a
he was a really really clever man he
kind of self-taught himself
to be like uh
he was an amazing artist and stuff and
he started working at a company where he
upholstered office furniture right
and he worked his way all the way to the
top to become general manager after 20
years
just just an incredible man you know but
he was working with a guy who was the
boss of the company who [ __ ] drove a
ferrari and had a massive house and
you know i think my dad
was looking at him and thinking
why why haven't i got this you know we
were doing pretty good but it wasn't
this guy you know this guy owned the
company so
everything that we sold he sold was
going to him essentially
and i think he
i i was like 14 15 16 at this point
and he decided that he would go
on his own
um
which which now as a 50 year old i look
like him i think
first of all it was [ __ ] brave and
and b
you're an idiot
you know yes he had no capital you know
he had to
put our house up
against the [ __ ] he bought to make
chairs you know right
and so
one thing led to another and that
company
collapsed and and with the collapse of
that company
excuse me it meant that
people from a bank came
and they took our car and they
moved us outside of our house how old
are you how old are you at this point i
was 15.
my god and they changed the locks
on the house and that was it we had
nothing and he
he he changed you know he had
he had i mean i literally then it was
i didn't see him smile for [ __ ] 10
years i'd never seen my old man cry
and then that's all i saw him do
for
i mean for months literally for months
you know i think there was a big thing
with him and his generation where
he could not do what
was imperative for a man to do and that
was to look after your family to support
and provide you know
and he never got over that and he never
he was never the same again you know oh
that's got to be devastating
and stuff like that but
it was just he
it broke him you know it really broke
him but
you know 10 years after
20 years after that you know when he was
my
mum
saw him through that period of years ten
years literally when he couldn't get
[ __ ] dressed and he walked the dog
for eight hours a day collecting golf
balls and selling them to a driving
range you know that was his job that's
what he did
and my mum saw him through that you know
but at the same time wasn't she wasn't
she drinking at the same time though
yeah god yeah but you know she was
she was a powerful working class
welsh [ __ ] firebrand functional
alcoholic like a functional alcoholic
she could function she could get [ __ ]
done yeah i mean you didn't talk about
her drinking
you didn't mention it you know that's
what's what we do
you know
this is how it is on the sun you know
right but then it got to a point where
my mom was in her
50 probably
when she suddenly became
a very old woman you know she looked
like a [ __ ] eight-year-old
and then he
he got her through the next 10 years you
know they then flipped
flipped their jobs right
and i you know i remember
i think i remember [ __ ] hating my dad
for years and my mum you know
because i was always saying to him
what you know what are you
why don't you get up why are you crying
you know i was really mad at that you
know yeah i was really sad and maddie
uh
you know and then to see him flip and
then he you know he was like
he was amazing it was an amazing
thing to see you know
like essentially
i don't know just watch it must be hard
to watch
your
the love of your life kill herself
over 10 years 20 30 years and
just sit and facilitate it and
you know yeah
you know what's funny is i don't know
this is not funny but you know i would
have i would have uh
loved to have seen my father cry once
to show some emotion show some
vulnerability as a child it was just
always you get caught drinking you're
going to a halfway house you do this
you're out of the house this is the way
it is i never drank i never did anything
and all of a sudden
it was until my 20s when i went to my
dad's old dentist and i was like god did
my dad ever drink did he ever your dad
was [ __ ] doing coke he was [ __ ]
trashed he was wiggling his dick out at
everybody he was you know all this [ __ ]
that i found out about my dad later i'm
like why did you lie to me why are you
like this superhero
um you know and he you know he i don't i
forgive him but you know at the same
time
i would have loved to have seen some
vulnerability i would have loved to have
seen some more
nurturing caring
yeah and you you got to see probably too
much of that in the other direction
yeah i mean look the
the flip side was once my mum passed
away
he
i felt like he became free i mean
obviously he was very sad right and it
was awful but he he gained a certain
level of freedom you know
and
i said my uh
my dad only
lived for another eight years after my
mum died he died really early too
but but in that in those eight years you
know he
he fell in love he found a new lady who
was amazing an amazing woman and
you know he he he got his [ __ ] back he
was an art he was an amazing artist
amazing watercolorist
and uh
he got it he started he did it again i
hadn't seen him pick up a paintbrush for
25 years and he started again and i
could see him
you know i think that's probably why
when my old man died it was that was the
[ __ ] last thing for me in terms of
the straw that broke the camel's mind
you know i was like
okay so
i just got my [ __ ] best friend back
and i've had him for five six years and
now he's got [ __ ] lung cancer it's
like
dude you know yeah it was too much do
you think a lot of the art stuff that
you do now i look on instagram and the
beautiful art that you do and the
cooking it's all from the folks right
you get that from your mom and dad yeah
i mean yeah
it's just um
i think it's a real i
i don't know there's you see a lot of
people in our job who are [ __ ]
terribly who are terrible show-offs you
know i mean right and i'm not i'm like
oh my god sit down and shut up or
there's a petite i can't say but there's
a particular
youtube clip of this actor
and he's on like a talk show
and all of a sudden he's like doing a
selection of dances and impressions and
i'm like oh my god like i can't not
watch it but at the same time i i just
hate it so much it's like you desperate
you're
desperate for coverage
but so i've never felt that you know
right but
in the kitchen i can i can [ __ ] like
we have friends around today and i just
i like i made an amazing like plum and
almond tart and it's it's [ __ ] great
it's like that's that's my chance to
show off slightly
right so you love you love cooking you
love art you love you're a homebody you
like to be at home
yeah i do yeah because i think it's a
skill to cook now i mean yeah you know
not i mean not that many cook obviously
loads of people cook but
it's not it's not i mean
it's not massive that people can
sit and cook but you know
dinner every every night of the week or
you know so i'm kind of proud that
there's a
i know you know my ten-year-old
does stuff in the kitchen too it's like
i think that's a real good skill to have
you know
inside of you is brought to you by
fairway fairway meat market company is a
family-owned grocery chain and a top 10
employer in iowa it's been in business
since 1938 they have the most delicious
meats
the freshest meats you could possibly
imagine uh they sent me some and uh
i just freaking love it what'd you make
uh well pork tenderloin
yes delicious and uh easy to make uh you
know i just throw it on the grill that's
what i do i throw things on the grill
rib eyes and uh all that stuff they've
got the best stuff you could possibly
taste in your life ryan
nice uh fairway meat market's quality
meat comes straight from america's
heartland premium beef including choice
prime and 100 full-blood wagyu and
all-natural certified durock pork is
raised by family farmers and sourced
straight out of corn country giving you
access to the highest quality meat in
america you know it's pretty easy ryan
all you have to do is visit fairway meat
market that's f-a-r-e-w-a-y
fairwaymeatmarket.com you select your
favorite meat products and you stand by
your grill waiting to
throw that slab of meat on there and
have a little tasty dinner or lunch or
snack
you know what i mean very nice this week
my listeners can get the butcher's
holiday collection valued at 275
for just
169.99 plus free shipping when entering
inside at checkout the butcher's holiday
collection package includes
two 12 ounce usda choice ribeye steaks
two 8 ounce usda choice filet mignons
two eight ounce usda choice sirloin
fillets
four eight ounce 100 full blood wagyu
patties six eight ounce certified duroc
boneless pork chops and two pounds of
private labeled bacon that's more than a
hundred dollars off the best meat in
america this holiday season plus free
shipping nationwide that's fairway meet
market dot com promo code inside and
look for the butcher's holiday
collection codes give free shipping site
wide as well not just on the select
package that's fairwaymeatmarket.com
promo code inside and look for the
butcher's holiday collection inside of
you is brought to you by geico
uh i've talked to you guys about geico
before i'm all about comfort i'm all
about easy i'm all about hey if i'm i
don't want to go to the grocery store i
want people to deliver groceries to me
i've got a lot going on in my life and
you know what you've got a lot going on
in your life ryan yeah so what can you
do it sounds like you're in the market
for a bundling policy that's you're damn
right i am i'm in the mood for a
bundling policy policy policy these
holidays
do you understand geico makes it easy to
bundle your homeowners or renters
insurance along with your auto policy
why not be good to yourself
on the holidays just go to geico
get a quote see how much you could save
it's geico easy folks these wonderful
bundling policies make it easy for one
payment
and great deals
guycode.com go there today that's
geico.com even a rosenbaum can do it
you know it sounds like
you had a pretty good childhood but you
there's a lot of bad luck around you
there was a lot of [ __ ] that happened so
it was one of those things where you
loved your mom you loved your dad he
worked hard they went through some ruts
and i know you know i lost my sister uh
two years ago she she passed away she
was 14 and she was sick her whole life
but i know that you lost your sister
when you were 10 years old and she was
she was 18 and that had to be just i
mean to tear a family apart that's that
how did you how did that happen i mean
she had an asthma attack
yeah she did she was um
she was an amazing singer
and songwriter and she was just about
because she was from my dad's first
marriage so when my dad and her mum got
divorced they went and lived in new
zealand
and uh
so she was kind of about to break
over there you know and uh
she did a gig one night and she came
back and
and she just was on her own and
started to have a massive asthma attack
and just never couldn't
you know couldn't alert people and
and passed away you know and it was just
uh
it's one of those it was one of those
things that
i can't sit in a room now without the
television on
um
it doesn't have to have any sound on but
the tv has to be on
and that i think that is a remnant of
of
we were at my auntie marion's house
staying there when we found when we
found out but having to come down
um
and the tv was off you know my mom and
dad would just sat
just silently you know it was like oh
[ __ ] what is as a 10 year old i'm like
what is this what's happening here you
know jesus
and so you know
he said
it's a really odd thing
because after that you know my
my brother mark died when i was 30.
and then good girl two years later my
sister debbie died
and then
my mum died two years after that
and then my dad died and then another
brother
uh ian
all in the space of ten
ten years essentially
and it's you know
i
i kind of got really good at the [ __ ]
admin of it the admin of grief do you
know what i mean yeah
okay well i feel like this and we'll do
this and
let's book a car for these people and
is there a let's phone this florist and
but i never necess i didn't necessarily
got
to deal with the
other
bits and pieces of of that you know
yeah you were sort of like almost
facilitating like okay this is what we
got to do someone's got to step up i'm
going to get this i'm going to go to the
florist i'm going to do this and i'm
going to keep everything together here
we go but inside you're ripped apart
yeah of course yeah keep just keep going
forward
that was my that was my thing for so
many years just keep going yeah well i
mean you have to you have to keep going
forward i mean you stop you're kind of
[ __ ] aren't you
yeah yeah well i mean yes
in the end yeah
but that was it just it just [ __ ]
crippled me mentally in the end it was
like
it was just too much also because you
kind of
you get a certain level of success with
films you do and
you know you go to work and
you know people at work always see the
best possible nick frost you know what i
mean yeah because i [ __ ] love it i
love being on a set
and i love the focus pullers and i love
the costume guys
and getting my hair cut and
i love it all you know
um
i'm there for literally every lens
change i love watching them do it
you know i love them marking up there
sure
you know so to then
and to be fairly and and to be
successful in doing that job you know
yeah
to then have to come home
or you know you've happiness people have
an assumption that
you're a [ __ ]
laughing billionaire you know
yeah it's just not the case it's like
yeah you know you come home and you're
your life is [ __ ] i always say i was
sort of like you know it's like the
clown you you're up there with a big
smile on your face on set and
everybody's oh it's nick oh it's
rosenbaum oh they're just [ __ ] happy
look at them they're so funny they're
doing stand-up god these guys are so
funny and you go home and go i hate
myself yeah i [ __ ] hate my life
what is that i mean i i went through
years and years of that where i just was
like i give so much to everybody but
when i got home i was all alone i always
felt like alone
yeah
yeah yeah i think yeah that's um i think
that's
it's a really um
it's really
it's really [ __ ] crippling it's
really spirit crushing
to give so much you know and i think
that's also part of
the diagnosis that we have as people
with adhd you know we're i think with
people i'm a people pleaser you know oh
yeah i never realized that
the simplest thing was
i all i needed to do was just to be
happy myself
and that would make my kids happy and
that would make my wife happy yeah
i never imagined that that that's how
simple it was i just
even as a [ __ ]
48 year old man you know what i mean
just
literally
smashing doors down to make people happy
and it never did because they could see
inside that
i was just [ __ ] lonely and sad
what is it that fixes us i mean people
like us out there that um you learn to
love yourself you learn to just say all
right this is it this is what i've been
given and i've made a lot of people
happy and i've got to learn to love
myself it's easier said than done but to
be able to look yourself in a [ __ ]
mirror and go i [ __ ] love that guy
he's awesome
that's [ __ ] hard for my affirmations
yeah exactly do you do that do you do
your gratitudes or do you do things like
that or
yeah well yeah i mean
i do i mean i i've
i think i've learned a lot over the last
three years in terms of me and
how destructive i am as a person you
know and how how fragile it is to how
fragile i am and and it was and
um
and i think you get to a point i
certainly got to a point where
someone said to me
uh like a really young woman like in her
20s said to me like
you have suffered enough you you don't
need to suffer anymore and i was like
yeah dude
you know it was like you started crying
right you're so completely right you
know and i think
i don't know there's a few a few things
and
i think my my
my seven-year-old he was seven then but
him just kind of sitting next to me and
putting a little hand on my arm and
saying you were right dad it was like
[ __ ] i can't
you know
it's uh
that's what i
live for and and what
work to try and avoid him ever looking
like that again you know yeah how giving
yourself
you have purpose
yeah he's your purpose you know
yeah children are your personality all
three of them yeah
well three of the little a-holes all the
little bastards
um did you
what was it that got you into sort of
acting and like you know just like what
was it that you felt like i this is what
i need this is what i'm gonna gravitate
towards or i'm good at this am i am i
quick-witted there's something about me
that's different that i think i could be
successful about this
for with this yeah um
yeah well
no i mean i i was always just a [ __ ]
funny idiot at school you know
um i was like
like a uh i was like like a weird kind
of stunt man like fall off a wall or i'd
run into a garage door or i'd do a big
stunt on my bike or
and i was cheeky and funny and
you know just that everything you do to
try and cover up being lonely as a child
right uh and afraid
and but i was funny you know i
i lived when i was like 18 19 i lived in
palestine for two years and i made
people laugh and i was good at it and i
was a i was a waiter for years and i was
really good at that so i was
funny and smart and i made loads of tips
and
and i never my honest to god never
wanted i never thought about
not once did i get to a point of
thinking oh [ __ ] what am i going to do
you know i just never
i just never thought like that really
not that i didn't see it i just never
thought my parents never pushed them
right they never said oh now you need to
go to college or you know
i left school at six six just sixteen
i'd turned so
and then went to work at a company
um like a shipping company selling
containers
um
i was always the funniest
[ __ ] you know right and i think it was
only when i was at
chiquito's mexican bar and restaurant
that i kind of met simon and and
i never realized i never knew stand-up
was a thing
i i'd never i mean i had seen films but
i didn't know what cinema was
right you know i didn't
know you could get paid for telling
jokes or telling stories or being funny
being in it you know
and so i met simon and
we just made each other laugh just
all the time as you know it was just and
he said you why are you going to try and
do some stand-up
and so i thought yeah well [ __ ] it let
me yeah let me
let me do that you know
and i did 12 gigs
and
uh six were amazing
and six were like the lowest point of my
life
yes
i think i'd rather bury my mom again
and it just wasn't for me i just felt
like it wasn't
i didn't know why you know i never
realized that i just wanted to be great
immediately because i can make everyone
laugh in the pub yet right
i can't do that i don't know how to do
this i didn't realize it was
a fierce skill and you know you you you
do it for years before you get going
right and you didn't want to spend the
years with your add you couldn't spend
years to get good at it you're like i'm
not taking this time
uh yeah no i'm also it was like
suffering with anxiety of being around
loads of people and
it took a lot out of me you know i was
like
i'd have a big headache afterwards and i
just didn't like it because i was
thinking about it all day and i felt
like
that feeling you get before i've been
going to have a shot you know i was like
well i gotta do a [ __ ] gig so you
know i hated it just feeling like you
have to take a [ __ ] all the time
the nerves you have to take it [ __ ]
as you called it once a yankee long
you know yes but you know you that's the
thing
yeah it's like i've just been spent the
day eating steak and cake and then
having to push that out of me
and you feel like that all the time just
performing and getting on stage at 11
o'clock at night i know i've done it too
i did stand up for about i probably did
it for about almost a year and every
time i go why do you put yourself
through this and then all of a sudden
you hear the applause and you're like
because i love that but i hate
everything up to that i hate everything
up to the point of actually everyone
laughing
the whole day just feels like [ __ ]
i'm nervous i have to be great i put too
much pressure on myself but i still have
that now before every acting gig i i've
ever done
um
i will be up all night shooting myself
and being sick and
just being [ __ ] frightened of of
uh you know i think it's changed now but
but now it's about a fear of
failure you know a fear of
not knowing my dialogue and and
[ __ ] the production up and everyone
hate you know what i mean same [ __ ]
thing why is it that the older we get
the more we give a [ __ ] the more we're
worried about failure we weren't that
worried about failure when we were
younger
no no no but i've worked with a few
actors really big actors who come onto
the set
and and
didn't know any dialogue and had to be
fed line after line off the line and
laughed throughout and
and then just went home and i was like
you lucky prick they're just
feeling like that confident and
you know
but yeah i mean i just got after knowing
simon and stuff we
he wrote a show he wrote a show with
jessica heinz called space
right he said you just want you to come
and come and be a coward um i used to do
this character and he just said why
don't you come and do come and do this
character you know
and uh yeah that was it really that was
that was 20 odds 22 years ago so if you
never met simon what would you be doing
right now
i think i would be the area manager of a
chain of mexican restaurants
and you'd probably be okay with it
i'd probably run six restaurants in the
southeast
and i'd have like a nice company car
and what's wrong with that
[ __ ] nothing
low pressure geek
right
and you love cooking
oh my god yeah but you met simon and
everything [ __ ] changed and you
started doing all these movies do you
obviously shauna the dead was like the
first real big one right
yes
did you have any idea that that was
going to be as much of a success as it
was
um
[ __ ] no no i've i don't know no not at
all i mean
you know we we've always
told us to a certain extent
we've always tried especially the films
me and simon made
uh paul as well and cuban fury and
and then the ones i did with edgar and
simon it's
it was about making
us laugh and making our mates laugh and
and just a group of friends
who just wanted to have fun and make a
film and have a laugh and
you know
we love zombie films and now we get a
chance to make our own zombie film and
we love cop film and now we're making
hot files and i think it was only when
when we did the
the work the american press tour for hot
fuzz
i think did we realize how successful
sean of the dead had been you know right
because it was like when we did our tour
for we did such massive press tours for
these films
you wouldn't do them these days but like
for sean of the dead we did
28 american cities in 35 days or
something like that you know
and then for hot fuzz we did exactly the
same thing
and for world time funnily enough but
like
when we went to do sean the dead we'd
come to introduce the screening
and no one would really clatten or would
know us and you'd get a few people
saying well a space
but then afterwards they'd love the film
so people would go bonkers right but it
was when we did hot fuzz when we had to
go and introduce the film every night
the cinemas were [ __ ] rammed
and everyone went absolutely mental
every time he went to introduce the
screening
and it was like wow you know people
[ __ ] love sean today
one of my favorites i've seen it a
hundred times i'm a big i'm a big horror
movie fan if you came to my house you'd
see return of the living dead fright
night evil dead posters that's just kind
of like who i am you know yeah i love it
yeah um do you think that it's it's sort
of like
do you miss that camaraderie that just
trying to make each other laugh on set
and then what happens is inadvertently
or ultimately you get famous and then
people start wanting you in their own
projects but now you're not working with
these same people who you
live off of and and rip off of and does
that kind of do you kind of like when
you're on another movie set you're
probably like i want every movie set to
be like shawn of the dead i want the
jokes to always be coming and they're
not always like that
yeah look i i'm gonna say no i mean
as much as i i mean i love working with
edgar and simon and i would be nothing
without those films and
and and without the the chance
and and the gamble that those guys took
on me as a performer you know never
having acted before
you know i i'm aware that i kind of i'd
be i'd be the
area manager of six chiquito's mexican
restaurants right now but you know it's
it's also when you're friends like that
and and the more films you do the more
money you get given to make the films
the pressure gets more and more and more
so right you know friendships creak it's
difficult you know i know
it's i
it's easier to make films without simon
um
because it's like
i think being being a sidekick this is
like my big chip on my shoulder being a
sidekick and a wingman
it's very difficult to
be taken
as anything but that for things you know
and so i think i've spent
i think successfully the last 10
[Music]
years or so trying to move myself away
from that right um i'm very grateful for
it
but
you know i thought there was potentially
i felt i could do more as a character
actor
um i felt i had it in me you know i
didn't want to just
have all that [ __ ] death in my life
and then not use it right uh
or use it to sell kind of little bits of
weed to
uh you know ed's friends right so you
know it's also difficult because it's
we work hard when we did those films we
weren't there there wasn't much laughter
i mean it was great to do and it was fun
but you're busting your ass that was
[ __ ] hard you know yeah there's we
just worked we worked we worked we
worked because edgar
you know unfortunately we all shared a
similar work ethic in terms of let's
[ __ ] get it done let's do this you
know right yes it was fun
but the rehearsals were always fun
because then it was loose and we had
time and
and if something was funny and we all
laughed it would go in and then
that would be the shooting script you'd
use and then we only ever shot that we
didn't improvise we didn't
you know
but you yeah i mean
i i i also like the fact that edgar and
i and simon and i
have evolved our friendships have
evolved and because of that they they
have survived and there is you know
there is
there is as much love there now as there
was excuse me when we were 30 but now
it's like
i have three kids i have a a partner we
have my my mom you know my
it your focus changes that's just
naturally what happens is you get
as you get older you know because if if
you
if it doesn't you end up like [ __ ]
simon's character in the world's end you
know what i mean yeah
what it what's it like you know doing
something like into the badlands where
you're playing a badass or like playing
a character like that did you enjoy your
experience and you were in ireland
filming that
yeah we were there for two two years on
and off you know
um i gotta say me and daniel wu
and doing that show with miles and and
now yeah was
the [ __ ] best thing that happened to
me i loved that show i loved shooting it
um and the more we did you know
because the writers were in the states
and we were there you know sometimes to
get the scripts and
none of it would match up because it's
like the guy that wrote four and five
isn't the guy that wrote six and seventh
so none of it would match so
certainly for the second season the
third season i was in
um
you know i was getting to do little
rewrites and stuff and i'd go to allen
miles and daniel and say hey i rewrote
this scene what do you think and they
were like yeah boom let's put it here
then wow
al must allen miles must really love you
to allow you to do that
they're that i'm telling you and they
did it
yeah of course it was always you know
i never it was never i never said i
don't i'm never i'm not one of those
actors who says i don't like this or i
don't think my parents would say this i
always say hey
i'm not sure i said this but how about
this you know
what about this or
take it or leave it you know just make
people aware that you're
you know your placement food chain you
know right and if
it was always good it was always good
and funny and
touching and and
and relevant you know right
and i think that's i think that's a
i think that's something i really enjoy
about my my career is
i i i have a voice on everything i do
yeah you know even now doing the nevers
and i'm like number [ __ ] 40 on the
cool sheet
i i'm still allowed to say
hey can we can we you know can we try
this or what about this as an old tool
you know that's nice to have that
freedom where people respect you and
know that you're capable of doing that
so they kind of trust you you know what
i mean yeah oh my god yeah also
similarly there's lots of actors there
you know there are people on into the
badlands as beautiful as they were and
they were great at martial arts and
acted they if they didn't like something
they just say you know they just say the
words it's like but you don't have i
mean
you could
change it you know don't moan about it
change it right
this is called [ __ ] talking with nick
frost it's it's rapid fire questions you
can answer them
but this is from my lovable patrons if
you want to join patreon patreon.com
inside of you uh support the podcast uh
michelle k are the rumors about you
being the next doctor who true
also who is your favorite doctor who or
who gives a [ __ ]
uh okay so i have two favorite doctor
who's tom baker because he was around
when i was you know in 10 12
and um
i really loved matt smith and and
capaldi too i think those guys were
great
um
i
i did a like someone i saw something on
twitter the other day liked one of the
geek
websites did a thing
30 actors who we potentially could see
playing doctor who and like
i wasn't i didn't make that whole list
and so i was so
enraged that i even like put a thing on
saying did i not really make that list
at all
uh i don't think i mean i i
i i don't know enough for me but but you
would do it you would do doctor who
yeah i'm not maybe [ __ ] it why not why
the [ __ ] not emily yes what's been your
favorite project you have done so far in
your career i know there's a lot and
that's a tough one but the one that
really comes to mind
um okay so
[Music]
into the badlands was amazing i really
love doing fighting with my family with
steven merchant and i love steven too i
love him he's such a great guy
great
every all the cast was amazing
we all wrestled it was just like you
know when you it's just like
you know when you hit a tennis ball
perfectly and you can't feel it
do you know what i mean yeah like yeah
this is [ __ ] great we could improvise
we could do what we want and
and it was kind of i loved it it was
great it was like a love i got to have a
mohawk as well it was a lovely three
months yeah i really enjoyed it i really
enjoyed that a lot that was a lot of fun
um yeah uh what was it going to say oh
omar i love the world's end any funny
stories behind the scenes to that
uh funny story [ __ ] hell i mean
um i never really wanted to hit the
stuntman when we were doing the fights i
didn't like eating them
and then like
edgar's kind of a sadist
so like he'd come over just before like
when we were doing the fight scenes and
stuff he'd say hey listen i really want
you to hit him this time really got him
okay
uh
so like that and then you know they'd be
you'd see them like laying on the floor
and having like smell insults and
and then yeah i kind of got my
like brad allen who who did a lot of the
fighting uh who sadly died recently you
know
um he he was uh
one of um
jackie chan's guys you know and he gave
me the nickname the white samoa hung
and uh i don't think i'll ever forget
that
you don't like watching your uh your
stuff do you
you know i mean
what's the point
i mean because sometimes you're really
funny and you could be like wow you know
i'm really good in that i'm i'm enjoying
what i did in this
yeah okay i mean look i mean
[Music]
i watched bits i watched little bits and
pieces and i think okay that's cool
you know i did um
i did a we made a show called truth
seekers a couple years yup
and that was the first thing i'd ever
watched when i saw like the assembly
first episode one that was the first
thing i ever watched
all the way through and didn't cry
in terms of saying oh my god
you know i'm just being hypocritical
well again that's that thing it's like
i'd rather not watch myself and put
myself through
[ __ ] i can't change it now it's done you
know you made that choice artistically
and you have to live with that even
though i know secretly
it's pretty good you're pretty freaking
good yeah you know you're good
there's a confidence in that
yeah yeah something yeah sometimes yeah
what's the one with you i mean doing
white women kill with allison tolman and
stuff there was lots of lovely act in
there you know i was like
there was a few times working with older
actors who come in to do like
smaller characters who were like proper
broadway actors and
and also i did i did a film with a tv
show with olivia coleman a while ago
and like me and her got to do like a
[ __ ] 12-page drama scene together it
was like you have that thing where
you just i was watching it and i was
like oh this is [ __ ] this is great
you know
but
those are the things those are the
things i have to hang on to when
i hate acting you know because it takes
so much out of me mentally in terms of
oh i'm having to do a diarrhea now i
can't sleep i'm afraid
i'm afraid i'm not going to know my
dialogue
[ __ ] i'm you know it really takes it out
of me in terms of of of
mentally you know but of course once you
get on there and you've done that first
rehearsal
and you haven't fought your dialogue up
and everything's fine and then you just
start firing as the day goes you're like
yeah this is [ __ ] what i paid my
money for so many actors have that we
have that thing where
we're [ __ ] our pants i'm nervous i
can't do this i don't know why they're
going to find out the truth about me i
suck and then
yeah then you get on set you do it a
couple times and then you start to
forget about that and you are able to
relax a little more but it's like but
why do we go through this same [ __ ] why
can't we just be like those actors you
were talking about that are just [ __ ]
just do it and not worry about it i'll
never be that guy i don't think i'll
ever be that guy i got to accept it
yes yeah and there's something there's
something there that comes with that
level of acceptance
in terms of
this is my way this is what i do and
this is how i do it
and it works for me you know yeah do you
want to be challenged do you want to be
challenged more do you feel like you
could like do like a world war ii drama
and not be funny at all just be really
dark and and just oh my god yeah
absolutely yeah i'd love to you know
i'd love to do that i mean i think
i'm what i don't know i feel like i'm
going to say something that i don't know
but i just feel like
i don't know i'd like to follow kind of
look i don't i don't know what i'm
saying but uh yeah of course i would uh
it's um
it's a chat i like acting you know i
like it i like
i like
feeling these things you know
i like making people believe that
i'm this and i feel that you know that's
that's a real skill i think do you think
you'll ever start your own restaurant
have your own restaurant have your own
thing
yeah you do
no [ __ ] that it's too much like hard
work i don't know man the amount you
cook in the st you could just see the
passion flowing through the internet you
could just see it but it's a lot you've
got to be there all day you got to be
there
you know but if i you know what
sometimes i think if i could do find
that one thing
like i sometimes think about
i'm gonna use an american term like a
smash burger right right and [ __ ]
just do that right two
wafer thin patties with american cheese
fried onions and a nice bun it's like
boom five pound of pop
frost burgers
frost's burgers come what would the
title be
don't choke
don't choke burgers
yeah oh i like that that's it's in your
one
one in eight of our burgers have a tooth
in
oh my god hey this has been awesome man
i hope you enjoyed this this i really
feel like i got to know you like we
we've oh we've talked a few times and
this and that but i really i appreciate
you opening up and what what do you got
going on next anything that we could
look forward to
well we're still a baby so i mean
unfortunately i'm in a position where i
can say i would like five months off now
you know certainly help with that
so yeah listen we me and my girlfriend
are at a point where we do the same
thing every single day
and it's been that for three months you
know and we're just in a we're just in a
vibe where we just it's just parenting
and there's something quite nice in that
too
you know so um i read a book i read a
kid's book which i'm editing now
um and then i paint a lot too so i've
got
a few big things coming across to la to
show in the gallery and
bits and pieces can people buy your work
can they buy your art
where could they buy your art
um
to be tbc i'm between galleries right
now
but okay
yeah i'm just trying to
i'm working out some stuff but i i
really love painting so yeah
you know
i love it last lastly can i just say
something yeah i the thing that i liked
about you michael when we met
when we did australia is i just kind of
loved your naughtiness from the get-go
and it's kind of
rare in in
in humans that you just meet someone and
you just get them straight away and i
think that's why i've always had a keen
affinity and uh uh a fondness for you
because i'm like
yeah i mean
well i look man i love you i really
appreciate that i i felt the same way in
fact my buddy tom who was there with me
said tell nick i said hi but you won't
remember me but still you have that sort
of presence that people gravitate
towards i i just wanted to be around you
you're such a likable well you're such a
likable guy i really innately just feel
that way about you and i
i liked you all you're right off the bat
i was like i want to hang with this guy
how can i hang with him he's just i just
feel like you still do that thing every
now and again where i don't know if you
remember but you went you take that
guy's microphone and then you activate
the pa and the whole convention you say
supernova
we say that a lot
supernova yes supernova was a convention
we did in australia and i would take the
the mic and just start uh talking into
it and yelling supernova and uh they got
a kick out of that but uh by the way
lastly
a question you've been asked a million
times will you ever do another movie to
add to the cornetto trilogy
yeah [ __ ] i'm sure yeah of course we
will i don't know when but yeah we will
i mean listen what i say about this just
to close is i love the fact that when we
started making these films we were 28 29
and now we're in our 50s and soon we'll
be [ __ ] 60 odd so i it's a it's it's
really rare that you get to see
characters
age with the actors yeah and i think
we've we've been given a chance to to do
that you know and i think
i think it will be interesting to see
what what comes next you know well i
i've loved this ryan did you enjoy this
ryan's my engineer over there that you
can't see hey ryan
hey nick this was great this has been
fantastic yeah thank you so much man
i'll i'll be in touch with you and i
really appreciate you you're doing this
for me this is uh this has been a real
treat for me man yeah listen thank you
mate i appreciate it yeah give haley my
love will ya thanks man i'll see you
later
bye lots of love
i mean a lot happened in the episode i
mean he really talked about how he moved
in with simon pegg how he had no money
how his sister passed away at a young
age uh he was a big drinker he was uh
you know he'd be content having a food
truck
you know
um
just a genuine guy man i i really
enjoyed having nick on the podcast and i
hope you did too so if you like this
podcast please subscribe on youtube or
stitcher or apple or spotify
you can follow us again at
insideepodcast
on
instagram and facebook and insidipot on
the twitter
i really appreciate all of you listening
and uh
thank thank nick frost for being on the
podcast that was great he's calling us
from lovely london lovely london
where he was boggy london town
in london
um if you want to uh
shop on the inside of you go to the
inside of you online store we've got uh
we've got inside of you uh mugs we've
got inside of you shirts we've got uh
lex luthor pictures to sign we've got
some small the lunch boxes left
and uh the band
the band is sun spin if you go to
sunspin.com
uh you can look up for upcoming shows
and you could also get some really cool
swag there's some really great merch you
could book a zoom with me and rob and
chat with us
and uh all that sort of stuff so thank
you and again if you want to join
patreon patreon.com inside of you i
can't thank these guys enough who give
back to the podcast and keep us
afloat let me read off their names do it
nancy d leah
s tricia f sarah v little lisa u kiko
jill e brian h mama lauren g nico p
jerry w robert
p
jason w kristen k amelia oh alison l raj
c joshua d emily s cj p damn you're good
dude samantha m jennifer
n stacy l jen
take a wild guess
c
s yes that's correct jamal f janelle b
kimberly e mike eldon soprano 99 more
ramirez santiago and m is correct sarah
f chad w leanne p janine r maya p maddie
um
s yes belinda
uh and chris
f no h and dave who's between that and
dave h yes spider-man uh
two
no chase yes
sheila um
g correct brad
d
ray a
ch
correct tabitha d liliana
m a a michelle
b k k michael s talia m betsy d claire m
laura l chad l rochelle nathan e marion
meg k janelle p trav l dan l dan n big
stevie w angel m rhiannon c cory k super
sam coleman g dev nixon michelle a liz i
jeremy c andy t cody r sebastian k
gavin
correct david c john b brandy d
four yvores correct camille
ian s all right bono the c the c
or l c in spanish
joey m willie f christina e adelaide n
jeffrey m omar i lena n design otg
eugene and leah chris p nikki g corey
ktb patricia and maria
ann and oh is it marla
is that marla in
i think it's marla
oh i'm gonna say marla ann and maria and
just in case all right
but uh hey guys
thanks for thanks for listening to the
show thanks for tuning in um gosh i wish
i had more to say but i really don't
other than um another fun podcast
another fun interview for me i'm hope
hopefully you uh you enjoyed it
yourselves and uh from myself michael
rosen i'm here in the hollywood hills of
california myself ryan tails
we love you guys thank you for joining
us and spending some time with us thank
you for allowing me to be inside of each
and every one of you be good to yourself
please be good to yourself i'm gonna try
and be good to myself let's breathe
take care
[Music]